m
oh
non
le président mitterrand prend fait et
cause pour le projet de loi joxe sur
l'immigration le débat à l'assemblée se
poursuit ce les journalistes étrangers
est rappelé à l'ordre en chine plus
question en principe d'interroger les
chinois sur la situation toujours
confuse
le premier reportage or de pékin à
tianjin sida les séronégatifs peuvent
abriter le virus à l'état dormant
une étude américaine ouvre un nouveau
flanc à la rochère roland garros jérôme
potier créer la surprise
il va matar le vainqueur de nord
madame monsieur bonsoir tentative
d'assassinât avec responsabilité pleine
et entière
tel est le chef d'inculpation que le
juge d'instruction a signifié ce soir à
jocelyne ceccarelli la mère du petit
raphaël retrouvé hier aurait tenté de
faire disparaître l'enfant tout en
prétendant qu'il avait été enlevé
dominique tierces sont manquait qu'un
qu'il a créé mais qui est ce que
quelqu'un aurait un quincy donc cette
déclaration cacherait selon les
enquêteurs une incroyable mise en scène
celle d'une femme qui semble-t-il n'a
pas convaincu les experts en psychiatrie
jocelyne ceccarelli a été inculpé cet
après-midi de tentative d'assassinât
le juge d'instruction l'a déclaré
entièrement responsable de ses actes
pour les policiers saussines ceccarelli
a précipité son enfant du haut d'une
falaise juste en contrebas de ce virage
raphaël qui a deux ans a été sauvé par
miracle sa chute a été stoppé par un
palier dans la montagne
ce soir le père de raphaël doit être
consternés lui même a été entièrement
abuser par les premières déclarations de
sa femme jocelyne ceccarelli a été
écroué à la prison de nice
les chercheurs qui se bat contre le sida
doivent désormais compter avec une étude
américaine qui met à mal un certain
nombre de conclusions que l'on croyait
acquises étudiants un groupe
d'homosexuels à haut risque des
chercheurs de l'université de californie
ont découvert que près d'un quart
d'entre eux sont infectées par le virus
bien que les tests de dépistage du sida
reste négatif un constat qui prouve les
limites de ces tests mais qui révèle
aussi un autre comportement du virus
daniel duigou la découverte américaine
repose sur l'observation depuis dix ans
d'un groupe de 133 homosexuels
californien les prélèvements sanguins
réguliers ont été effectuées grâce à ces
prélèvements des médecins ont réussi à
identifier chez 31 d'entre eux le virus
du sida alors qu'ils sont restées
séronégatives séronégatifs c'est à dire
que leur organisme n'a pas fabriqué
d'anticorps qui sont les seuls éléments
repérable par le test de dépistage
autrement dit pendant trois ans pour 27
d'entre eux notamment
il était porteur
du virus sans que les tests en puisse
identifier la présence la méthode
expérimentale semble sûr car les
chercheurs américains ont identifié les
caractéristiques du virus
les conséquences surtout sont
importantes d'abord en ce qui concerne
le risque de contagion chez les gens qui
peuvent donc ignoré pendant plusieurs
années qu'ils sont porteurs du virus
pendant ce qu'on appelle déjà
l'infection silencieuse on assistera
encore plus sur le fait que la
prévention doit être fait non seulement
chez les séropositifs mais évidemment
chez des séronégatifs et que la
prévention doit être prise en charge
encore une fois par la population
générale
deuxième conséquence importante c'est un
nouvel espoir dans la découverte d'un
traitement si les données de l'étude
sont confirmées notamment par d'autres
équipes médicales cela veut dire que
l'organisme d'un quart des personnes
infectées par le virus arrive à bloquer
la multiplication du virus
c'est là un axe de recherche essentielle
dans la fabrication d'un nouveau
médicament qui stopperait l'action du
virus chez ceux dont l'organisme est
défaillant mais comme toujours en
recherche il faut rester prudent et
attendre la confirmation scientifique la
semaine prochaine à montréal où plus de
dix mille spécialistes seront réunies
tandis qu'à l'assemblée nationale le
débat sur le projet de loi joxe sur
l'immigration s'enliser s'envenime
le président mitterrand apporté
aujourd'hui son soutien au texte mis au
point par le ministre de l'intérieur il
a soulevé la question sort dans un
discours à chambéry première étape d'une
visite sur les sites olympiques des jeux
de 92
bernard pradines nous devons comprendre
la présence des étrangers chez nous dit
monsieur mitterrand et leur appliquer
notre loi pour le chef de l'état
la proportion des immigrés en france ne
s'est pas accru le pays a besoin d'eux
on oublie qu'ils sont souvent chargés
des tâches pénibles
il faut donc respecter appliquer la loi
et pas davantage toute fraude à
l'immigration sera sanctionné mais tout
étranger ayant obtenu le droit de vivre
ici sera protégé dès lors que nous
acceptons pour des raisons d' équilibre
du travail
la présence chez nous d'un certain
nombre de ces personnes
nous devons les
traiter comme on le doit
quand on est le pays de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme
et s'il faut se servir et il faut sévir
de temps à autre sans tomber dans cet
incroyable vi qui consiste à prétendre
que il suffit d'être étranger pour être
délinquant il quand il faut sévir
alors respectons les formes de nos lois
et puis c'est tout ce que je demande
pour monsieur mitterrand ce coup de
pouce au gouvernement au moment de la
discussion de la loi joxe à l'assemblée
n'est pas le fait du prince
allusion à une critique de monsieur
chirac et le chef de l'état rappelle
qu'il avait annoncé la couleur
pendant la campagne présidentielle de 88
le président du cds permet une grille à
lui critiqué aujourd'hui la tactique du
gouvernement à propos du texte joxe une
opération cynique et politicienne at il
dit qui consiste d'abord à gauchir le
texte ensuite à provoquer le débat avant
les européennes à me vais procéder at il
ajouté pour renforcer le front national
et affaiblir l'opposition
retournons en savon au reste on dit le
président dont inauguré le siège du
comité d'organisation des jeux
olympiques d'albertville en compagnie de
jean claude killy d' michel barnier et à
val d'isère il a décoré franck piccard
champion olympique à calgary
une manière de voir voici donc franck
piccard décoré de la légion d'honneur
une manière pour le président de la
république de saluer l'effort de toute
une région qui se prépare au jeu de 92
parfois avec difficulté dans le cas des
petites stations mais souvent avec en
train comme malade ou skis l'a vérifié à
méribel partout des travaux la
municipalité décidé de jouer à fond la
carte des jeux olympiques
ici à méribel se dérouleront les
épreuves de ski alpin féminin
de hockey sur glace il faudra que la
station soit digne de l'événement
affirment les responsables s'étaient
partie des travaux d'embellissement de
la station le centre de méribel qui
était prévu même sans les jeux
olympiques bien sûr et qui feront qu'à
partir de juillet sera une zone presque
entièrement piétonnière avec ou sans les
jeux olympiques donc ces travaux étaient
effectués on accélère un peu c'est tout
mais mes anciens pour regretter le passé
il n'en est pas question bien sous ce
seul jour et la nuit
travaux d'embellissement coût 25
millions de francs financés par la
commune en plus les futures
installations 100 millions de francs à
partager avec le projet le comité
olympique derrière vous avez un parking
actuellement qui viendra la base de
l'emprise de la future patinoire
olympique qui est dont les travaux vont
commencer sous quinzaine
à cela s'ajouteront un bâtiment pour les
sponsors et la presse plus un stade de
slalom
méribel 13 cents habitants un budget
digne d'une ville de 18000 habitants
grâce au tourisme
pour le maire les comptes sont bons il
n'ya pas fuite en avant la participation
de cojoux de 70 millions et 30 millions
de la commune
je crois que c'est tout à fait
raisonnable pour la commune de merida
donc il y aura pas d'augmentation des
impôts locaux
pas du tout mais attention les calculs
ont été effectués en fonction d'une
progression légère au pire d'une
stabilisation du marché du ski en 1992 à
albertville lire at il encore un jean
claude killy pour redynamiser la
pratique du ski les médecins scolaires
étaient en grève aujourd'hui à l'appel
du syndicat national autonome des
médecins de santé publique
vous ne vous en êtes probablement pas
aperçu dans la médecine scolaire est
clairsemé en france un médecin pour 10
mille enfants les explications de marie
françoise millions
plus d'effectifs un vrai statut
voilà les deux principales
revendications des médecins scolaires
un vrai statut car ils sont ballottés
entre le ministère de la santé et celui
de l'éducation nationale plus d'effectif
car un médecin pour 10 mille enfants
n'est pas assis on a dit que l'état
santé des jeunes et s'était améliorée
que la situation ne fait plus aussi
dramatique après la guerre il n'empêche
que cela n'est plus du tout reconnu
actuellement des indicateurs sanitaires
montrent que les enfants sont toujours
en mauvaise santé
même si les problèmes de santé se sont
déplacés beaucoup d'enfants et
d'adolescents ne sont pas suivies par un
pédiatre et médecin de famille
pour eux aussi il est important de
contrôler régulièrement entre autres les
dents l'audition et la croissance les
exploitent points visibles au cours de
la scolarité mais en réalité faute de
médecins seule la première visite avant
d'entrer en primaire est assuré à 100%
je suis médecin moi même ce super djata
il devrait avoir droit à un audiogramme
déjà au cp ça devrait être obligatoire à
dépister un dépistage oculaire tous les
ans au moins et vu par un médecin
scolaire au moins deux fois dans leur
scolarité
collège quand on a trop s'ils viennent
moi mon coeur moi j'ai pas les lycées à
la fin de la troisième
aujourd'hui certains affirment qu'il ya
trop de médecins généralistes la
médecine scolaire pourrait constituer
une excellente reconversion pour remplir
pleinement son rôle il lui faudrait au
moins doubler ses effectifs
ouverture aujourd'hui à paris du 50e
congrès de l'union des hlm michel
delbarre le ministre de l'équipement et
du logement annoncé plusieurs mesures du
gouvernement pour fallait faciliter
l'accession sociale à la propriété
l'occasion pour jean pellieux de nous
montrer comment fonctionne amont
notamment une régie de quartier ou
comment les habitants des hlm prennent
eux mêmes en main la revalorisation de
leur cadre de vie
ces jeunes de la cité répare des stores
ils sont treize ans page dans la régie
de quartier associations d'habitants
créé il ya quatre ans abderrahmane et
son moniteur vont changer des siphons
coût 300 francs un plombier prendrait
mille francs pour les jeunes il y à un
autre intérêt c'est l'apprentissage d'un
métier il faut tout le temps commençait
pas un stage s'en prend on va pas avoir
un autre présent aux pros tout c'est
comme ça âgé d'une trentaine d'années la
cité hlm souffre des maux habituel des
grands ensembles logements vides et
graffitis plus de la moitié des immigrés
africains sur toulouse et de nombreux
chômeurs l'office hlm s'efforce de
revaloriser les immeubles transformation
de logements bureaux comme ici travaux
d'isolation etc
ils assurent les grosses réparations les
locataires l'entretien courant elles
sont 55 locataires comme justin à
nettoyer chaque jour les couloirs à
faire des remarques aussi aux autres
habitants 700 francs par mois pour un
travail à quart-temps un salaire
d'appoint pour je signe mais surtout un
engagement et ses propres cellules
les gens sont heureux dont ils font déjà
beaucoup plus attention à ce qu'ils font
ils mettent le paquet par terre dans les
courses il est évident que les enfants
jouent dans les coursives et qui met du
sable qui ont fait ça alors ça
comprendre certaines choses locataires
parce qu'ils sont tellement habitués à
vivre là où c'était sale avant
maintenant de ses propres sons du mal
qu'on prend et vous avez envie de rester
ou partir
sauvaître australien ici je sais que
soient partagées mais là j'aime
l'appartement un truc chine ferait bien
trouver un autre ici on reste ici une
centaine de locataires assure ainsi
entretien et dépannage pour le compte
des habitants et de l'office l'office
dont le personnel s'arrête de travailler
le vendredi soir le fait que des
habitants qui habitent sur ces mêmes ces
mêmes d'immeubles puisse intervenir et
interviennent à des heures samedi le
dimanche en soirée et créera présente un
avantage au niveau du service très
important l'amélioration du cadre de vie
c'est l'effet est évident de la régie le
nombre d'impayés a été divisée par 3 des
gens reviennent habiter ici une
reconquête certes fragile mais qui
montrent peut-être que rien n'est tout à
fait perdu quand les locataires se
prennent en main la société dassault va
t'elle braver le ministère des finances
et conclure avec l'irak
un nouveau contrat d'armement le
problème se pose parce que l'irak
mauvais payeurs doit déjà quelques 25
milliards à la france et que ce nouveau
contrat de 22 milliards qui bien sûr
renflouerait la société d'armement et
bien pèserait encore sur le contentieux
financier gérard leclerc c'est l'une des
vedettes du salon aéronautique de
farnborough comme du bourget le mirage
2000 d'assaut en a déjà vendu 169
exemplaires à six pays dont l'egypte et
la jordanie
alors que l'armée française en a
commandé plus de 500 mhz évoluera-t-il
demain dans le ciel irakien
malgré le démenti de circonstance du
constructeur d une négociation ou bien
été engagées avec le gouvernement du
président saddam hussein pour la
livraison d'une cinquantaine d'appareils
soit 22 milliards de francs
malheureusement l'irak exemple après sa
guerre avec l'iran ou et déjà une
quarantaine de milliards à la france et
ne propose de rembourser pour l'année en
cours que le huitième de ses arriérés
d'où la méfiance du ministère français
des finances qui n'accordera les prêts
nécessaires que si l'irak fourni les
garanties
une sorte de bras de fer est ainsi
engagée entre dassault qui met en avant
l'emploi de ces quinze mille salariés et
une commande qui ré sinon aux
soviétiques et le ministère qui dit
refuser que les contribuables ne payent
l'armement
d'un pays étranger attention à
l'inflation pierre bérégovoy demandent
aux constructeurs automobiles de montrer
l'exemple en matière de prix journée
d'action cgt aujourd'hui dans la
construction navale demain doit se
réunir à paris une table ronde sur
l'avenir industriel du site de la norme
aide à la ciotat la reconversion s'avère
difficile pour ces ouvriers
même si l'expérience est plus positive à
aubagne françois joly lui jacquet a
derrière lui vingt ans du chantier naval
depuis plus d'un mois ils travaillent
dans cette entreprise de poterie son
nouveau patron mirabel a ouvert cet
atelier dans la zone entreprises
d'aubagne une très bonne affaire
pas d'impôts sur les bénéfices pendant
dix ans seule contrainte créer dix
emplois en trois ans lorsque j'étais
religion nous allons perdre ici gyan de
nos inventaires zones d'entreprises
c'est un druze a été fait pour justement
remplacer le personnel dano remède
nous avons joué le jeu en main que nous
avons demandé de suivre le responsable
un élément d'une clique de la norme
aides en 30 ans le chantier j'étais dans
l'artisanat j'ai travaillé pendant 13
heures dans le bâtiment
donc en revenant à ce milieu j'ai pas
été surpris si vous voulez
à aubagne depuis 1987 avec la création
de la zone d'entreprises
ce sont plus de 300 emplois nouveaux une
réussite mais qui ne concerne pas les
anciens de la normale seules 14 d'entre
eux travaillent sur ceux ci
dans cette entreprise quatre ont été
embauchés ils y sont restés en tout
trois et six mois
et puis sont partis les ouvriers de la
ciotat ont vécu pendant un grand nombre
d'années dans un univers un peu fermé
sans tellement communiquer avec le monde
extérieur et ils se sont retrouvés 15
ans après pour certains d'entre eux ou
dix ans après à devoir aller ailleurs
j'ai l'impression que c'était pour une
transplantation et les transplantations
ça réussit pas tout chaud
question d'adaptation pour les anciens
de la navale mais aussi problème de
salaire dans leurs nouveaux emplois ils
gagnent entre 40 à 50 % de moins qu'au
chantier
enfin à aubagne si les normes elles ont
toujours pas trouvé leur place c'est que
le chômage frappe
au delà des chantiers vous avez la
vallée de les vols vers marseille l'est
à l'ouest juste qui a amené à pain et
perdu des centaines et des centaines et
centaines d'emplois avec des familles de
la commune qui habite sur la commune de
banne la ciotat vient se surajouter à ce
phénomène et les hommes d'entreprise
soit disant destiné à recevoir les
licenciés de la norme est ne faisait que
recevoir les demandeurs d'emplois de
l'ensemble de la région
alors peut-être la solution pour les
normes aide cette zone d'entreprises à
la ciotat même un site encore en
gestation
car ici il faut tout reconstruire une
image de marque ternie par des années de
conflit un tissu industriel qu'il faut
diversifier
après un siècle d'activité uniquement
tourné vers la mer l'instruction du
français de paul touvier retardé
l'ancien chef de la milice arrêté le 24
mai dernier sera bientôt opéré de la
prostate dans un hôpital civil il est
toujours à l'hôpital de la prison de
fresnes en chine
ou plutôt à pékin à la situation reste
confuse les trois ouvriers interpellé
avant-hier ont été relâchés aujourd'hui
après une nouvelle manifestation en leur
faveur et la municipalité de pékin avait
signifié aux journalistes étrangers de
nouvelles mesures pour les empêcher de
travailler
pas question notamment d'interroger un
chinois sur la situation actuelle
alors qu'en est il en réalité bruno
l'adresse d'une mesure est pour
l'instant n'est pas mise en application
aujourd'hui encore avec l'équipe
d'antenne 2 comme d'ailleurs la plupart
des journalistes qui se trouve à pékin
nous n'avons pu faire notre travail
il met prendre des photos interviewé
même dans la news y public que la place
tienanmen
il est clair que le gouvernement chinois
peut être les moyens policiers ou même
militaire de faire appliquer la loi est
interdite également l'occupation de
tienanmen par les étudiants mais il est
également clair qu'il y répugne
peut-être par crainte d'en animer la
situation il faut cependant noter
qu'outre fur et à mesure qu'ils
consolident pour pouvoir le premier
ministre lee bung rose le ton il
pourrait bien finir par passer à
l'action pour la première fois depuis le
début des troubles bruno carette l'un
des journalistes d'antenne 2 a réussi à
quitter pékin il a accompagné un
étudiant qui étaient venus manifester
dans la capitale et qui rentrait chez
lui à tianjin
son reportage il a retardé cet instant
aussi longtemps que possible mais il
faut s'y résoudre
c'est l'heure de partir sur le parvis de
la gare de pékin ils cherchent d'autres
étudiants des compagnons de voyage
recherches vaines
ils craignaient un train bondé des
difficultés pour acheter son billet tout
se passe bien
les journaux chinois explique pourtant à
longueur de pages que les étudiants de
province rentrer chez eux par dizaines
de milliers chang à 23 ans élève de
l'institut de technologie de tianjin à
150 km au nord de pékin
il vient de passer onze jours sur la
place tiananmen
mon plus grand souvenir restera la nuit
ou li peng a décrété la loi martiale sur
la place tous les camarades ont crié
l'ipec démission on a chanté toute la
nuit
tout le monde était très ému on a pensé
qu'on allait se retrouver en prison mais
il nous fallait continuer il fallait
faire trembler ce gouvernement
finalement les paye à choisi une bonne
tactique
il a joué sur la fatigue et sur l'usure
des étudiants vous savez nous n'avons
que quatre années d'études supérieures
alors s'arrêtait deux mois c'est énorme
sur le campus de son université
l'atmosphère est plus tendue que dans la
capitale
les étudiants nous conseille de ne pas
rester dehors et de les accompagner dans
leur dortoir
la banque doit raconter pékin tout dire
les manifestations gigantesques les
nuits trop froide de tiananmen
l'enthousiasmé le soutien de la
population puis en lui fait visiter la
nouvelle fabrique de tracts
même si leurs moyens sont plus
rudimentaires les étudiants de tchin
tchin sont tout aussi mobilisé que ceux
des prestigieuse université pékinoise
il ne veut pas juger notre mouvement à
court terme nous avons semé les graines
désormais le peuple si ce qu'est la
démocratie il faut préserver la
mobilisation du peuple
avec lui nous pouvons défier le pouvoir
quinze jours durant
john va devoir reprendre ses libres il
doit obtenir son diplôme mais ils
restent toujours mobilisés
même s'il espérait que tout serait plus
simple plus rapide énorme manifestation
la nuit dernière en arménie soviétique à
erevan pour fêter la libération de neuf
militants nationalistes qui avaient été
emprisonnés à moscou après le
tremblement de terre de décembre à
moscou le congrès des députés du peuple
continue de faire sensation
après une diatribe féroce contre le kgb
les soviétiques on peut entendre en
direct à la radio un plaidoyer pour la
souveraineté des républiques baltes
aux etats-unis le président de la
chambre des représentants qui est le
troisième personnage de la république
il a dû démissionner motif des
accusations de magouilles financières
michel mompontet quel député américain
aurait imaginé il y a un an seulement
cette scène la tribune du congrès jim
wright le troisième personnage de l'état
mains tremblantes su en est réduit à la
plus humiliante des décisions
à l'origine je démissionne les premières
accusations dirigées contre lui il avait
pourtant fait sourire mais aujourd'hui
il jette l'épongé
le comité d'éthique du congrès elle
accuse en effet de 69 violation des
règlements parlementaires l'accusent de
pots-de-vin et d'achat l'influencent lui
et sa femme se serait produit nous ment
enrichit la politique américaine serait
elle en train de dévorer ses propres
enfants au nom d'une morale inflexible
les victimes tombent des deux côtés john
towers bois dit on il ne sera pas le
ministre des affaires étrangère de
george bush garia l'huile est infidèle
il ne sera donc pas candidat aux
élections présidentielles si ça continue
à lâcher ce matin député inquiet seuls
les séminaristes et les fils de famille
imbéciles pour en siéger dans ce congrès
de toutes les vertus sorte le président
bush en visite officielle à londres
aujourd'hui ils dînent en ce moment avec
madame thatcher et perrin
première journée du président américain
à londres au cours de laquelle madame
bush a créé la surprise en [ __ ] la
main de denis thatcher l'époux du
premier ministre britannique
plus sérieusement les entretiens entre
george bush et margaret thatcher ont
permis aux deux pays de réaffirmer leur
relation privilégiée le couple
présidentiel s'est ensuite rendu à
buckingham palace pour déjeuner avec la
reine elizabeth
une pétition universel pour le droit
d'assistance humanitaire lancé
aujourd'hui par le secrétaire d'état à
l'action humanitaire bernard kouchner
cette opération vise à rassembler sur
des cahiers géant un maximum de
signatures afin de demander aux états de
ne pas s'opposer à cette aide en cas de
catastrophe
ces cahiers seront exposés le 26 août
prochain à l'arche de la défense
premier voyage de jean paul ii en
scandinavie le pape a commencé sa visite
de dix jours par la norvège dont il a
salué l'esprit de solidarité et
d'hospitalité
devant plus de 18000 personnes le
souverain pontife a célébré une messe en
plein air au cours de laquelle il a
souhaité le rapprochement des
protestants et des catholiques collision
en plein ciel entre deux hélicoptères
militaires au dessus des jardins de la
villa borghèse et à rome les deux
pilotes ont trouvé la mort les deux
copilotes sont sérieusement blessés mais
le bilan aurait pu être beaucoup plus
lourd ce parc étant généralement très
fréquentée des raisons de l'accident
sont toujours inconnues
le besoin de visa pour les etats-unis
paris et washington ont conclu un accord
pour lever de part et d'autre les visas
qui était jusqu'ici indispensable mais
attention la mesure ne prendra effet
qu'en juillet renseignez-vous donc si
vous devez partir
à roland garros aujourd'hui gérons petit
a fait mieux que yannick noah il a lui
battu le brésilien amat argent ma mère
et oui christine et c'est la grande
satisfaction pour la france aujourd'hui
une satisfaction laquelle il faut
ajouter également chez les féminines la
victoire de karine contre ecc qui a
éliminé la britannique sarah gomer alors
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui il y avait
plusieurs rencontres y avait deux
groupes
le groupe des français le groupe des
grands alors parmi les grandes
chandelles d'aci lendl wilander echenoz
kof se sont qualifiés en revanche chez
les français j'en ai plus difficile et
si les françaises aussi élimination
d'arnaud boetsch chez les hommes et
éliminations de deux mondiaux de
nathalie guéret et de pascal etchemins
10 chez les féminines
mais il y a tout même maintenant trois
français dans le tour suivant avec
notamment jérôme potier que nous
retrouvons sur le court
jérôme potier submergées j'ai émergé de
bonheur est submergé par les télévisions
après sa victoire en cinq sets sur le
brésilien matin jérôme potier numéro 131
mondiale non seulement a fait une
performance mais en plus il avant
juillet noah tombé au premier tour face
à ce fameux matar matar un bon serveur a
rencontré un potier bons retourneurs
effectué les essais environ côté très
offensif même après avoir mené 2 sets 0
et a obligé de disputer un 5e set
potier n'a jamais cédé cela a eu pour
effet déclaré matar et pour la première
fois de sa vie donc jérôme potier jouera
les seizièmes de finale à roland garros
un moment important dans la carrière de
ce joueur est aussi un moment important
dans sa vie c'est un joueur talentueux
mais c'est surtout un joueur qui a
beaucoup beaucoup d'humour
pour n'importe quelle chance et je viens
ici c'est fabuleux c'est le plus grand
soin est actuellement sur le flanc
matériel comment vous vivez
karim khan 13 aussi n'a pas caché son
plaisir financiers de se qualifier pour
les seizièmes de finale mais karine
contract n'en a pas moins réalisé une
très belle performance sportive en
éliminant en trois sets la britannique
ghoreir après l'exploit d'éliminer
claudia côté kitsch au tour précédent
car ils tenteraient 4 confiance en elle
elle peut désormais aller très loin
elle peut aller loin disco au tour
suivant en rencontrant que des reines
africaines du sud qui est à peu près le
même classe ont le même classement quel
dans la 80e place mondiale
quant à jérôme potier rencontrera au
tour suivant l'américain duncan derrière
nous il y a un match en trombe fort je
dirais puisque ronald agenor l'haïtien
de bordeaux comme on l'appelle est
opposé à l'américain tim mayotte pour
l'instant les deux hommes en sont à un
set partout et chaque joueur a pris son
service pour l'instant égalité 3 partout
dans ce troisième set
une rencontre qui sans doute ne se
terminera pas ce soir nous aurons
l'occasion de les retrouver demain sur
le court sur le court
et oui il y a les arbitres il y a les
spectateurs et puis il ya aussi ce que
l'on voit moins ce sont les petits
ramasseurs de balle il ya en tout 150 au
tour de roland garros en vain garçon est
à peu près 30 filles alors avec son club
de la garde et philipp etter nous sommes
allés vivre un petit peu avec les
ramasseurs de balles de roland garros
ridha le responsable du ramasseur est
déjà là la journée d'un ramasseur
commence tours 6e réunion pour chacun
reçoit les dernières consignes et le
gourou d'office ira ensuite remise des
serviettes des balles et aussi de la
petite glacière contenant les boissons
rafraîchissantes pour la journée
puis c'est le départ pour le travail on
travaille de privilégiée obtenue après
une sévère sélection est incertain
d'entraînement
quinze jours d'un travail lui vaut bien
de toute façon l'école ils pénètrent sur
le court avant tout le monde prépare to
install tous peuvent même s'approcher
des grands comme gabriela sabatini il
emmagasine des souvenirs ça va il était
très gentil parfois les joueurs se
livrent à quelques pitreries agassi veut
faire sans doute oublié les colères de
mcenroe collectionneur il faut tout voir
de nettoyage et remercie jamais rien à
personne
et oui comme vous pouvez le constater
ramasseur de balle n'est pas toujours
facile
voilà qu est-il on se retrouve demain
avec un match fort important puisque
tulasne sera opposé à florian un match
entre le français mais un beau match de
16e de finale
à demain genre atmosphère atmosphère
quai de jemmapes à paris ce matin une
manifestation réunissait les amoureux du
quartier et du cinéma qui veulent
empêcher un projet immobilier de prendre
la place de l'hôtel du nord dominique
verdeilhan drôle de drame pour un hôtel
du nord un hôtel menacé de disparition
au grand dam des nostalgiques d'un
cinéma populaire de 1938 un hôtel
aujourd'hui délabré objet de bien le
convoitises
on a l'impression que un certain nombre
de décisions ont été prises à la ville
de paris au ministère de la culture pour
l'abandonner aux spéculateurs et nous
voulons sauver ce lieu parce que même
les américains quand j'étais à la mairie
qui parle de l'hôtel du nord
ils viennent ici non respect à l'endroit
de deux visites et allan watt tourisme
en fait l'hôtel du nord mais aussi le
canal saint martin et sa passerelle
filmé par marcel carné ont été
reconstruits en studio par le décorateur
alexandre trauner c'est pourquoi
l'immeuble du sang 2 quai de jemmapes ne
peut être classé monument historique
mais
et ça vous gênerait aussi vous
oui
vous auriez l'impression qu'on touche un
peu à votre pauvre car c'est un peu
votre oeuvre
c'est devenu le synonyme de montée
gardez la façade de l'hôtel du nord
c'est ce en quoi s'engage l'architecte
un immeuble d'habitation s'appuiera
alors sur la célèbre paroisse la seule
façon de mettre en valeur de restituer
cette image
cette mémoire collective sur l'autel
c'est de garder que cette seule façade
et ne pas de faire un monument
historique
un local au rez de chaussée pourrait
être consacrée à l'histoire du film et
de ses interprètes mois l'atmosphère
le 15 juin la commission des sites en
accordant son feu vert au projet donnera
peut-être la dernière réplique à cet
hôtel du nord
les résultats du quartier de chantilly
annoncé le tir c'est donc c'est toujours
à chantilly le 4 le 9 le 8 5 francs dans
l'ordre rapporte 2535 francs et dans un
ordre différent 507 francs il y avait
aussi un kart et 4 9 8 et 3 5 francs
rapporte 22 1924 francs 50 et dans un
ordre différent 1271 francs voilà
laurent cabrol va vous parler du temps
dans un instant
henri sannier vous présentera notre
dernier journal vers 23h15 et vous avez
rendez vous comme tous les matins avec
télématin partir de 6h30 télématin
britannique
demain comme tous les vendredis rendez
vous européen avec roger zabel très
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20
heures